the sacrifices that you've made over the
years I'm not actually sure if I can
repay you for again I'll set now dear
mom I love that you can spell every
single word in the dictionary when I
need to what's up you and ask you how to
compose emails and letters dear Martin
from watching you you have taught me how
to be a badass when I needed you you
dropped everything your work your social
life your own relationships to be by my
side in a difficult time not only
difficult for me but for you and dad you
raised me pretty much on your own and I
can't imagine that to be very easy
you've taught me acceptance and not to
strive to be somebody else or search for
change in unchangeable situations you
always made sure your kids always had
even if it meant that you would go
without and the sacrifices that you've
made over the years I'm not actually
sure if I can repay you for even if I
tried when I was single and alone you
were best friend to me but more
importantly you were the ultimate
hospital buddy
staying every night of me before surgery
sitting of me and recovery sometimes I
was boring son as I was depressed
sometimes I've said nothing to talk
about because I didn't do anything of my
life but you were always there to watch
daytime telly with me and help me heal
from the inside and out
[Laughter]
[Music]
having to leave my daughter at hospital
after she came early literally broke my
heart in two I blamed myself because I'm
a petite woman I kind of thought my body
just couldn't handle pregnancy and that
maybe I just wasn't ever meant to be
alone
I blamed myself more so just because of
like the job that I do now social media
and people would make me feel like it
was my own fault
people would say things to me like I'll
be surprised if your baby survives
because your bump is so small and then
it would scare me and I really think
that my baby wouldn't make it this fine
had you back Jade don't you worry when
you said about you know the hours we
spent in hospital together we always
tried to find the funny side of things
didn't we always try to make light of
what was happening because it helped
helped us both I'm so proud of how far
you've come
thank you know you're not a selfish
person you know you give what you can
no I don't care about that you're good
to me you look after me I'm just
grateful well you be the daughter that
you are you've grown so much in yourself
and I'm just so immensely proud of you
just keep doing what you're doing Jade
and you will get firm don't bother we
people what they got to say just
just do you
[Music]
you